everyone please welcome Priyanka Chopra
[Applause]
[Music]
Bianca Chopra opens up about taking her
husband Nick Jonas's last name gravity
of it it's like a big deal it's cool I
didn't realize it was that much of a big
deal till I did it wasn't it big did you
did you talk about maybe not taking his
name Oh Jonas yeah um no I always wanted
to add his name to mine because I feel
like you know we're becoming family and
I'm a little traditional and all school
like that yeah but I don't take away my
identity
he gets added to Who I am the 36 year
old actress was a guest on Tuesdays
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon where she
dished on her upcoming romantic comedy
isn't it romantic
I'm Josh he's such a beautiful name
and got candid about married life with
the former Joe bro it's different yes
it's very different so ok so I lived in
New York before and Nick lived in LA so
now we share both our homes now nothing
works in my house
because I'm never in my house so my
coffee machine doesn't work the air
conditioning makes some sounds it's cute
my house is beautiful but like there's
just nothing works and everything in
Nick's house is immaculate
like his alarms work he's like light my
doorbell doesn't the actress who shares
plenty of adorable pics of her beloved
pup diana on instagram also told a
hilarious story about one of the first
time she stayed over at her immaculate
hubby's home my dog peed on his carpet
the first dude oh my god he's like he's
like what am i doing I went through
everything cleaners baking soda like
scrubbing serious elbow grease got it
out you did but he's still noticed hey
say yeah yeah
[Music]